Russian mercenaries swapped trenched
Warfare in Ukraine for armed Rebellion
at home
their leader vowed to march on Moscow in
the gravest threat to Vladimir Putin's
rule
it triggered heightened security Global
scrutiny and this extraordinary
statement from the president
this is a criminal adventuristic
campaign it is equivalent to Armed
mutiny
Russia will defend itself and repel this
move we are fighting for the life and
security of our citizens and our
territorial integrity
it is an attempt to subvert us from
inside this is treason in the face of
those who are fighting on the front
this is a stab in the back of our troops
and the people of Russia
the uprising by the head of the Wagner
mercenary group put the country on a
knife edge
but with a convoy of his Fighters
closing in on Moscow yevgeny pregosin
seemingly blinked Wagner
company they wanted to disband us we
started out on the March for justice on
the 23rd in 24 hours you reach within
200 kilometers of Moscow over that time
we didn't shed a single drop of our
men's blood now though the time has come
when blood might be shed therefore
mindful of the responsibility that
Russian blood might be shed by one of
the parties we're turning our columns
round and moving off in the opposite
direction to the field camps according
to plan
the U-turn averted the prospect of
internal Warfare inside Russia for now
it marked the latest twist in a day of
Confrontation and confusion hours
earlier Wagner forces seized the city of
rostov ondon on Russia's Southern border
the Wagner boss said he was seeking
Revenge after accusing Russian military
Chiefs of killing his men in Ukraine
even though they're fighting on the same
side
we are in the military headquarters
rostov's military sites are under the
control of the Wagner Fighters including
the air base jets that leave for combat
depart in normal mode there are not any
problems
in reality this wasn't a problem but a
potential catastrophe for President
Putin
an explosion shook a second City while a
missile just missed a military
helicopter
in the chaos an oil Depot was set Ablaze
the head of Wagner claimed Russian
forces were targeting his men as they
pushed towards Moscow
on the streets of the capital there was
a heightened security presence but no
sense of panic
information is tightly controlled here
and loyalty to the president still
strong
you know we have to listen to Putin in
this case and support him
I feel very negatively about pragosan
because no matter what happens you can't
go against the government against the
president in a combat situation he's a
clear enemy
Ukraine and its Western allies watched
the spectacle unfold making their own
interpretations
the man from the Kremlin is obviously
very afraid and probably hiding
somewhere not showing himself I am sure
that he is no longer in Moscow he calls
somewhere and asks something he knows
what he is afraid of because he himself
has created this threat
[Music]
by Nightfall Wagner forces appeared to
be making good on their word to withdraw
the Kremlin was also making peace saying
pragosian will no longer face criminal
charges and instead will relocate to
Next Door Belarus
whether it was all just theater or a
genuine threat to the state one thing
certain the drama in Russia is far from
over
Deborah Haynes Sky News
[Applause]